how's the gum resin it's pooh-bah today
we're gonna play the last of us
remastered it sorry what it's not the
last of us it's Chuck Nadeau I'll [ __ ]
that I'm not playing that [ __ ] you take
Edgar and I'll play this game is that
the deal all right we're gonna play
sharknado IGN rated this 10 out of 10 so
it has to be [ __ ] good guy
[ __ ] sake he's already trying to miss
it this up all the cables I'm trying to
look cute on me I haven't seen the movie
I've seen the title and I felt like yeah
that's enough there's a movie about
sharks in a tornado in case you didn't
guess that lets check it out Oh
what a great [ __ ] start to the game
so you can slide and you can jump on
sharks Wow
they took temple run and replace it with
sharks
amazing for some reason I expected more
I don't know why I made that I got gosh
I he's trying to break my high score
what is this oh I ran through the shark
way I'm surfing maybe on a pink him
my ears are bleeding I'll finally its it
over I got a chainsaw what does that do
Wow all right good chain saw all those
Jack natives what's that this vacuum
Liberty's head what the [ __ ] oh god I
hit the Statue of Liberty
whoa this Jif animation has like almost
four images in it this is a ps4
exclusive when the graphics are so good
I don't I don't know of course the game
is microtransactions why wouldn't it all
right
we almost got all the checks in the
shake native it exploded running on
trucks now that's pretty impressive and
I collect sharknado coins which I can
then either buy with my real money who
the [ __ ] would do that you may have
tricked us with candy crush but we're
not gonna fall for this [ __ ]
all right surfboard and the water just
came out of nowhere
oh god I have to listen to it again oh
my god I got a blue team so I felt like
I'm playing this game for your Bryce I'm
playing it so you don't have to waste
money on this piece of [ __ ] this long
heart explodes in in because why not
maybe the shark had some dynamite who
knows what do I know they're sharks
honestly you know what this game is not
even that bad I think people just hate
on it because they didn't think of this
idea first the fact that you can what is
what is the idea of the game oh yeah
ripoff temple John that this like the
thing is the Sharks aren't even moving
I could technically sense still and I
would be fine if I just start running
towards them goddamn tornado we'd all be
fine Oh God
okay oh I'll have to waste my chums
they're so precious to me but I can't
afford you don't have enough chumps get
more yes so I could buy four thousand
three hundred buckets of chum you're a
walking fish massacre no I'm a walking
[ __ ] idiot if I do that correction
fun fact no sharks have ever been
recorded what did it say playing this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know so I got a reward we're beating
stage two what is the reward it is a
picture of a house
Wow so satisfying what is the reward for
stage 1 a picture of some money it's
almost like I'm rich
that was sharknado probably the game
that each not like but hey now you know
you're welcome
if you enjoy this video thank you for
leaving a like and commenting as always
thank you for hanging out with me
birthday it's a breakfast for you
roughly yes